- Are you scared to do it
because your parents won't like it?
- No, my parents actually support me--
- Okay, so what are
you afraid of, failing?
- Not failing... but...
Still being at the same place,
when my friends are at the next level.
- Huge mistake.
You don't want the same
things your friends want.
So why the fuck do you
care what they have?
The biggest reason people
are unhappy right now,
is 'cause they value
somebody else's opinion
more than they value their own.
Have the conversation
with the person that's holding you back.
The reason most people who
are listening right now
are not doing that thing,
is they're worried about
the opinion of somebody.
(echoing)
I am so devastated that you actually let
your grandma's point of view,
your mom, your dad, you
sister, your aunt...
You still let somebody else dictate based
on their opinion.
Every action you do, and it's your life.
(clock ticking)
The reason I'm super happy,
is nobody can tell me nothin'.
My wife, mom, and daughter,
could walk into my room right now,
tell me I'm a piece of crap,
and I would be 100% un-phased.
That is some gangster emotional structure.
If you're not feelin'
it, find new friends.
I'm being dead serious about this.
This one is real big for me.
The only way I've seen,
now that I'm older, that
you can build confidence,
is if you surround yourself
with people who are optimistic.
Start trimming your friend group,
and start adding to your friend group,
predicated, on what you wanna be.
Like, it's unbelievable
what happened to me
when I got into the Silicon Valley world,
and started meeting like, Mark Zuckerberg,
and like, Ed Williams and--
like, Travis--
like, it changed my life.
Everybody in this room,
needs to cut out as much of the noise,
and time of people that are negative,
and spend as much time with
people that are positive.
The people you spend time with
are the ones that dictate your mindset.
- Yeah.
- You could limit your time with your mom.
You could limit your time
with your best friend.
You could tell your girlfriend, or husband
to go fuck themselves.
- Yeah.
- You fuckin' roll up with
your dad, your mom, your sister,
and say fuck you, I'm out,
because you're a fuckin' toxin,
and I'll see you in six years,
if you figure out why the fuck I left.
You're accepting to be
in that relationship.
If you feel motivated
by this conversation,
or you're intrigued by it,
add one new winner friend.
Like, you know what I mean?
Add one new winner friend,
and cut one loser friend.
- I feel like even when I give it away,
and I don't speak to them,
the chatter of them--
- That means you--
That means you value their opinion.
- Yeah.
- I don't.
- Yup.
- Please, let this be
the video that drills
through your head, that
your life is predicated
on when you get real quiet,
and you can't hear another
fuckin' person's two cents
that has nothing to do with you,
and everything to do with
where they are in life.
Are you really gonna let
those eight or nine
people dictate your life?
'Cause you are so fearful
of judgment from others
that at the end of the day when you're 87,
you will not give a fuck about.